if you're a certain age kind of my age
this is a film that you desperately want
to see
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so i am a child of the 80s and early 90s
and i would love to see certain projects
from back in the day get made into
movies and one of those projects
is the thundercats movie but
this is a project that i
am equally excited about and equally
terrified about for the reasons we'll
get into in the video but could it
actually happen could there be a
thundercats live-action movie
well it's a project that's been on and
off the books for quite a while but it
looks right now that it's actually gonna
get made
simon barrett brought us godzilla versus
kong and he is really excited about
potentially making a thundercats movie
and it looks like they even have a
director on board with adam wingard
winger has recently done a couple of
interviews and in one of those
interviews he talks about seeing that
the bit in kong vs godzilla with the
hollow earth scene and he actually said
oh my god this is what i want the
thundercats movie to look like and then
he started to get very excited that
actually he suddenly realized that a
thundercats movie was actually real and
actually possible
but
this is where i get into the fee a bit
they want to do a live action movie
which would be part cgi and part live
action which is no problem cgi's got to
an amazing levels nowadays and could
really really work
but then i think about things like cats
that recent project where they all
looked completely psychotic and insane
and i wonder what would a live action
movie thundercats actually look like and
more importantly who would they get to
play chittara oh jitara
again if you're a certain age
you'd understand where i'm coming from
samyuk's art actually did this mock-up
where he imagined what certain stars
would look like if they actually
appeared in the thundercats movie and i
have to admit lionel as henry cavill
is genius and that can actually really
really work even though
he's too old to be lying for me lionel
needs to be a younger character the
whole point is that he's supposed to be
you know an older teenager early 20s
he's not really supposed to know what
he's doing he's supposed to be a bit of
an idiot the thundercats lionel call
them that would be admitting failure
where who cares about failure we need
them
it's a matter of honor i cannot call
them
panthro chitara and um
take tiger what was his name the tiger
dude anyway um it's supposed to sort of
like be his mentors and supposed to not
really agree with him all the time and
think he's a bit of an idiot sometimes
and he's supposed to grow into the role
you know so um i do think henry cavill
maybe is a little bit old but
look at this image he looks amazing they
also thought of a few other characters i
particularly like andy circus mumra i
think that is again a moment of genius i
can imagine his voice and i think that
could really really work who he picked
for chatara
margot robbie margot robbie could
actually do for this project what she
did for suicide squad basically a
terrible movie that people watched
because of margot robbie so you know
that could work but i actually again i
think that's a little bit obvious i'd
love to see somebody new come through
somebody you know that's that's really
exciting a really great actress but you
know with that sex appeal sorry
why do i actually think this project is
really on the card zone really going to
happen well certain actors have already
started talking about how much they
would love to appear in the role if it
happened so i i we were just talking
about this i pre-existed like the whole
pokemon like anime
like stuff all that i i wasn't in the
comic books any of that stuff
um so i was a big um
thundercats
like oh
i uh
my goal is to when they make the
thundercats movie i want to be the blue
the blue dude um
what's his name mom
and panthera that's who i want to be
when i grow up anthony mackie has been
appearing in loads of marvel movies he's
obviously done the winter soldier and so
on um he is an actor that's doing a lot
of projects for netflix at the moment he
was like me that you know we would watch
thundercats that they
that would start then you know as soon
as the episode ended me my brother's
like i'm panthro and just batted each
other
that was that was our childhood we
didn't have youtube and stuff we had
cartoons to enjoy
so you know this was our imagination
expressing itself and you know it always
turned into a fight but you know three
boys together in a room what's gonna
happen you're gonna batter each other so
i wouldn't worry about that um but
anthony mackie is again that roughly my
age and
this is what he grew up with and this
sort of project he'd love to do
so do i think one this is gonna happen
i think it will
um i'm surprised it didn't happen a
couple of years ago to be honest when
there's a big 80s revival and people
very interested in that and there's a
few other projects on the go at the time
but to be honest i'm glad it didn't
because this is a project really that
the cgi is going to have to catch up
with they cannot just stick a bunch of
fur on
and it work because it wouldn't
um
or you know some false teeth or whatever
it just wouldn't work there's going to
have to be an element to see giannis and
hopefully the makers will look at what
they did with cats and correct it
and do something you know take that
project to the next evolution to do
something that's really exciting and
really good
and what i really don't want them to do
is to look at
the the new project that was done a few
years ago so in 2011 there was a reboot
and it was terrible
let me show you what it's capable of in
the proper hands
[Music]
oh catch
[Music]
the book told that it was the
thundercats our ancestors who first
defeated mumrah it was the thundercats
who brought law and order to a world of
warring animals
um i did watch it it was awful this
tried to throw in like an anime type of
style and it just didn't work it was it
was just bad
wingwood the director hopefully this
project has said he doesn't want to do
that he wants to reboot the 1980s story
he wants to bring that back to the fans
so you know we might get to see the
thunder tank now
that is something like that was
something i used to build out of my lego
i used to watch thundercats and then i
used to build that thing and i i wanted
to be panther that was my that was my
thing i don't know i know i could do one
i want it to be panthera i am not
impressed panther
you're no work of art yourself you scaly
reptile
let's see what you've got slide so you
know that's what i'd love to see i want
to see the thunder you know the cat's
castle with the arm that lifts up the
tank was oh i want to see all that so
let's see if this project actually gets
made
so i apologize about my voice i've got a
bit of a head cold but if you are new to
the channel please ignore that like and
subscribe anyway and
also you could consider becoming a fully
placed side tracker please hit the join
button there's merchandise sidetrek.com
there's a link in the description all of
these little things they really help
support the channel so please as always
stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you